là sự khác biệt mạnh thất, tớ chất giảng kết tinh và chất giảng cô đi tình.
Vậy sao?
Đặc biệt không phải là sự khác biệt mạnh thất.
Còn nha, thì mà hơi nó hai không này mạnh thất nó khăn nhau ở đâu đi.
Đúng rồi, chính xác, mạnh thất nó khăn nhau ở đâu đi.
Mạnh tinh hệ, ngon, kết tinh thì chất giảng là tổng chút tinh hệ.
Tình giảng mình học xo niệm, khoảng gối chất giảng cô đi, thì không có có chút tinh hệ của thế thôi.
Vậy sao? Tất nhiên cái này là đúng này.
Cái này chỉ là thông bị mạnh thất này.
Cái số 2 là chất là tinh nó có xác có gì đổ nóng chảy xa đi.
Con vôn thì có cái này cũng...
Qua...
Chất giảng kết tinh có tinh xí hướng hoặc nạn hướng có chất làng vôn, cái đẹp hướng này.
Chỉ có cái này hồi khi nghe ra nó có tinh có thể rất liệt tốt, thì cái này nó không có nhiều ai.
Mạnh hơn là liên có hoặc xo hơn, thì xưa rất liệt nó sẽ phụ thủ khoảng bật lộ các hạm liệt tự sòn.
Chúng ta sẽ thích nó là nhiều khi mình cũng khúc khảm mình được là chất làng kết tinh có thể rất liệt tốt hạch hạch hạch hạch hạch hạch.
Chúc cái gì? Tuyệt tình trường hợp.
Làm mình cũng bộ lại xin là phán lại em, phó lời là phó.
Thấy đáng loại là thế là thích lại cũng bộ đi phán lại.
Các bạn xem loại là nhiều lộ quen nữa, có thể có bộ rút các bạn xem phán lại đâu.
Sêm nó loại là bây giờ lại chức tiếp.
Được rồi.
Cô bà nha, khi quan sát sự mắm thầy của mình khủ đúng, đã lấy thịt tụ đông nóng ngoài tục vi này.
Thông xuất quá trình của các bạn hấm trời, dần thình nước, nhìn lộ của khối, hệ này xanh như thế nào.
Cô lại đơn giản trên, lời, cô lại quá đơn giản, lộ đa bán đi.
Nhanh ngọt đa bán nào, đa bán gì nào?
Ok, nhìn lộ của này xe sao cho các bạn hấm trời của bạn nhỉ?
Được rồi nó giết không gồn ý thôi.
Đúng rồi.
Chúng ta nên mạnh cái chức đáng hấm trời.
Mà hấm trời, thì khi đáng hấm trời, chắc trắng như độc phy giết không gồm.
Nó như vậy, như vậy, lấy đáng tục đông đông ra nóng, phải có như độc âm đúng không?
Và lúc này nó xin lập sang rời như độc của nóng trời, phang lên.
Phang phản rất là mở năng hóm trời.
Y giữ xuất thông gồm, nóng bây bụng này.
Trời khi bạn bộ khối đuạn tạm nét.
Chúng ta, hệ, lý thịt bà ấy nó bán như vậy.
Hói hảy như vậy?
Chúng ta, hảy không em, hảy dịt hảy thảy bím tệm, hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy?
Có bố nóng đi nào?
Một trân lòng của nãy hoi.
Hãy nửa là phân biệt tụi tầy về sự mây hơi.
Mà sự sôi.
Ở đây là nó về sự mây hơi, những nó sẽ là mỏ gì đâu.
Mà dính thảo đó, bề mặt trân lòng.
Nhưng mà dụng nó bây hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy.
Mà hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy hảy
có bình xài, các bạn có bình dịch tình như thế nào?
Gọi, trước khi nào, tụi sấu,
phá biểu nào, sau khi là sai khi mà bệ tổ chút và tính chất của chức ạng gồn thì hình.
Nhưng cái chức ạng mà chúng ta sẽ bệnh từng nặp dạm chúng,
hình bệnh.
Nha, su hướng bề để học năm nay là rất bệnh.
Và năm tới nó mà tì nóng xe bệnh này.
Màng bây giờ chúng ta lấy ông người ta ăn bì câu đầu tiên thôi.
Vốn điểm giới đầu tiên thôi mà mình mấy em là chết rồi.
Nhanh bộ đầu tiên cũng có một quân số mà chắc chắc chắc chắc bạm phải đáng để mà khi dữ.
Hình có hay là nóng lọc đi đồ lỗi xe trong bạn,
ở gần bụng bệnh chắc,
thì sao học xe,
hay, hay cái tạm,
đi thi học năm bệnh rồi, là dưới năm điểm.
Dưới năm điểm, rất là thật dưới là chúng ta,
là sai hãy tình chắc như đầu tiên.
Nó đến từ biệt là chúng ta,
kính thức nó phục chắc chắn,
đến từ một rượt cho các bạn còn này nó thật sự chắc chắn là như vậy.
Nếu là người ta có thể hiểu sai nhé,
ở đây là người ta có thể hiểu sai,
để xa,
đúng rồi,
thôi là sai,
nhé là người ta có thể đứa,
chắc xắn của mình vẫn chắc là lúc được ở tính đặt hướng,
ở đây là là có tính gì cũng là sai rồi.
Hãy không nghĩ nó sẽ chắn như nhà đúng.
Đi nóng cũng mẹ đi được tư dưới nóng trên lọc à đúng.
Lại sao?
Ừ, ok mà.
Thì tích nhập đường hợp lạc của đi mà, là vị đúng cho nó có thể gà đúng.
Ừ, thôi,
nó xuống lại,
khi một chất chuyện kể tư dưới lọc,
Đúng rồi, vô mẹ nó phân tử có lên, đúng rồi, vô hoàn phân tử có lên, vô chết rồi, đi.
Không phải.
Cái gì là bạn thân là gì các bạn?
Đúng rồi.
Tích thơ phân tử mà, nó có thể đổ lòng.
Không, lý thể, tích thân phó, điều gì.
Đúng rồi, tích chuyển, nó sẽ lòng qua để phí vị, khoảng cái cấp phân tử tăng lên.
Lý thể cấp phân tử, nó sẽ phá quân, luôn vào.
Hình ra là gì các bạn, tích thích của nó, mấy cân lên nhiều lần.
Chứ không phải là phó, điều mà, đẹp.
Bây giờ, nó có thể phó là, các phó tử, mình có nhiều thì có hẹn nó phy con, các phó tử phy to lên là phó tử.
Bây giờ, xe, vô rồi, nhau, ở đây, xe, nhau ở đây, xe, nhau ở đây, xe, nhau ở đây,
nó có phó là, tông số, đá màu, có thể có điểm này.
Hết tự nương tụ là khoảng cình được là, có khoảng cình nào,
có thể cho điểm ở em ơi, nên trong không bình luôn, thì có các bạn có này nào.
đúng rồi, nó chính là khoảng cình của xe, hứa hứa hứa,
có thể nào, có thể hình chuyển được đẹp đứa thế gián,
nó có thể có khoảng cình nào đó là.
Đâu chỉ luôn, nhau, mấy, đâu chỉ lên, có cho điểm.
Hãy có hai câu lại đi, hai câu cho điểm, cho có bạn thôi.
Đâu, không hai câu cho điểm này.
Nha, đâu, đâu, không trai đúng rồi, đây chỉ không.
Nha, chỉ ra khu chỉ nó mì.
Hãy cho, đây là là sự thương khoảng, nhé, chuyện với thế gián xác tệ tí,
nó là thương khoảng.
Nha, tốt số người, tốt lộ bây hơi cũng muốn chân lòng, phụ thuộc,
và những díu đấu nào, sau đây.
Nào, tốt lộ khoảng cơ dụ, một chân lòng, phụ thuộc, và những dụ nào, sau đây.
Hãy dấu lúc thấy, bây hơi đồng ý tượng mà nó sẽ gà mọng giữ đồ.
Nha, tốt lộ, nha, tốt lộ, nha, tốt lộ, nha, tốt lộ, xác bây hơi đồng ý.
Nha, tốt lộ, nha, tốt lộ, bây hơi đồng ý.
Tốt lộ, tốt lộ, nha, tốt lộ.
Nha, tốt lộ, nha, tốt lộ.
Gì đứng mặt quán, nó sẽ bởi vì mình nó phụ thuộc vào.
Cái này, các phân tự, bây mặt.
Chẳng như, nó sẽ tốt lộ, nó sẽ tốt lộ, nó sẽ tốt lộ.